[Music]
what's your name CYO sweet I'm Mr Miller
I'm assuming that you got one of these
before I read the whole list well
there's 12 books on that list party
heart always
said what is an
adult I'm
18 languishing in the Wilds of nowhere
Tennessee don't know I'll ever break
this
don't you get scared walking through
those woods I'm the scariest thing in
[Laughter]
there knew could
speech I want you to write a short story
in the style of your favorite author are
you offering me special treatment Mr
Miller well
uh John here is prepping her to be his
Transcendent is she pretty oh she's
talented damn even worse what are you
wring about I'm been inspired I've had
no achievement make him love you
I'll she open her mouth to say
[Music]
something but the words fell
away why did you write this this is
inappropriate right what you know is
what you said if you don't reite this
I'll have to fail
you
I'm dare
you it's like he's been living in Grays
scale and you're the first thing he's
ever seen in
color you are the adult show some
responsibility you're my student and I'm
your teacher that's
all if she can convince them had
something happened between us I could
lose my job it's not all you good L
you're going to ruin his life burn it
down it down it
down in your own words how did it start
said I a good
[Music]
kid